generally comedic I think we both got a
fashion show that you know he can dose
it can limit to me show me charge of he
America darky such me it's like you know
SATs me Reshma is on cloud nine
I have never seen a happier girl in my
entire life and she is just already she
is like started like packing her best
clothes
when I first met her she was in a lot of
shock all she wanted to do was kill
herself and she was in depression
hi girls Maharashtra admirable an evil
evil how to get perfect red lip
finally subset important tip red
lipstick up course a nice a Cohiba male
jz acid kita just give us a hollows in
Turkey acid attack you victim auntie we
live in a male-dominated society curing
a woman say no to one of your requests
or your demand I think that's where acid
attacks them from I think hashtags also
stem from this obsession that India has
with beauty and with fair skin and how a
woman's place in society is judged by
her appearances
there is nothing more beautiful than a
strong human being and for us to be able
to send Reshma to Fashion Week
you have a walk there will definitely
read a party and have people thinking
what beauty actually is and what it
should be